exactamente 700 personas era el permiso
que le había dado la ciudad de
washington a esta organización que pues
puso en marcha este día de protesta para
las personas que todavía están
encarceladas que fueron partícipes de la
toma del capitolio el 6 de enero le
preguntamos a varios policías acá en el
en el capitolio de sobre cuántas
personas se habían presentado nos
dijeron que alrededor de 350 personas
que no eran más de 400 personas y lo que
nosotros hemos visto acá en terreno es
que pues fueron obviamente muchos más
los policías que hicieron presencia en
este lugar y también los periodistas que
así que eran más los periodistas que las
personas que vinieron a manifestarse lo
que inteligencia y reportes de
inteligencia dicen es que la
comunicación interna que hubo entre los
simpatizantes de donald trump pues lo
fue tan activo en redes sociales y en
medios de comunicación conservadores
como sí lo fue días antes de la toma al
capitolio el 6 de enero
había también temor temor según muchos
reportes de inteligencia de personas que
se presentaran acá personas que hacen
parte de estos grupos que ya conocemos
como los cloud boys y los softwares que
fueron grupos que incentivaron esta toma
del capitolio el 6 de enero que ellos no
se presentaran acá precisamente por
miedo a que las autoridades pues los
investigarán más tuvieran más
información sobre estas personas que
pues siguen de forma organizada llevando
a cabo este apoyo a un otro anp y este
apoyo a las personas que pues siguen
arrestadas por la toma del capitolio el
6 de enero
cristóbal el expediente donald trump
tomó distancia de ésta a marjah que dijo
al respecto
tomo distancia el expresidente dijo que
esto era algo coordinado para hacerle
daño a los republicanos dijo que si
efectivamente poca gente se presentaba a
esta marcha pues entonces los medios de
comunicación iban a decir que faltaba
impulso que faltaba apoyo que le falta
apoyo al partido republicano y al
tropismo y que si las personas que se
presentaban eran venían en gran número
pues que estas personas iban a ser
recriminada les iban a ser maltratadas
por parte no solamente de los medios de
comunicación sino también de la fuerza
pública así que don afronte cia que esto
era un 3 pierde por un lado y pierde por
otro lado lo que me llamó la atención
después de hablar con los organizadores
de esta marcha es que no vieron como en
los ojos que donald trump haya salido
públicamente a decir que esto había sido
una marcha en contra de los republicanos
lo que ellos argumentan es que son una
organización que crearon esta marcha y
esta impulso por venir a apoyar a las
personas que siguen arrestadas que
participaron la marcha del 6 de enero
pero que en ningún momento ellos se
afilian con el tropismo que son una
organización según ellos que no tiene
ningún carácter político sino que
simplemente pues busca para apoyar a la
gente que sigue presa después de ocho
meses y que según ellos puesto sigue
presa porque son prisioneros políticos
llama también la atención que a cerca de
dos millas de acá en la plaza liberty
hay una congregación también de cerca de
100 personas muchos de ellos que se
califican como antifa que pues están en
contra de estas marchas diciendo que no
son prisioneros políticos y que deben
estar en prisión gracias a cristóbal por
este completísimo reporte desde la
capital estadounidense